don't stop the ball in transition he's
gonna put it on your head
simmons count it and one ben simmons
answers back
goes right at marcus smart and a chance
for a three-point play
a prior possession and he's coming with
bad intentions
he's off balance his feet are not right
this is a tough move
against a physical defensive player
plenty of time over four minutes left
ben simmons with the steal and simmons
goes up and throws it down he did this
the other night made some big defensive
plays down the stretch
jalen make the tough shot over you it's
the beauty of being 6-10
strong drives inside right-handed flips
it up and in
nine points here in the fourth quarter
for ben simmons
simmons wisely will walk it up the floor
now drive
side step right handed off the glass is
good ben simmons exploding offensively
some passing but what a fourth quarter
for him how about the euro step helps to
be ambidextrous
and this is a tough shot look at the
length because of the separation